jean vincent brisset est avec nous en
direct sur arte france
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
recherche à l'iris spécialiste de la
chine doit-on s'attendre à de nouvelles
tensions commerciales entre washington
et pékin jusqu'où est ce que ça peut
aller
alors lui tensions commerciales entre
washington et pékin n'ont jamais cessé
on est dans une phase où il ya eu un
accord cadre qui était signé comme vous
l'avez d'en parler au mois de janvier
on est dans la négociation après cet
accord cadre est fidèle à sa technique
trump fonctionne à un coup de pression
il met de la pression là où il peut à
chaque fois un parce que cette idée en
plus dans une phase de réflexion
il est dans une phase où il en va rendre
des comptes sur la manière dont il a
géré la cuisse du coronavirus donc tous
les moyens sont bons pour accuser la
chine de tous les maux et se montrer
comme mais tant l'homme fort vis-à-vis
de sa propre population
les responsables américains accusent
huawei de voler des secrets commerciaux
la chine appelle les états unis à cesser
sa répression déraisonnable envers why
wait y croire au final le cas de rama
est extrêmement intéressant parce que
roy ouais comme comme beaucoup de choses
en chine est en train d'essayer de
s'imposer au niveau mondial et d'essayer
d'imposer des normes chinoises depuis
plus d'un siècle
on essaie d'imposer des normes
internationales mais ça s'est appelée
américaine standard associé chez sas et
appelé d'autres industries normal c'est
devenu iso international
c'est devenu international et les
chinois voudraient imposer leurs normes
les normes en particulier au niveau de
la scène g20 qui représentent quelque
chose d'énorme comme comme marché et
huawei pourrait être le leader mondial
avec des normes chinoises mais le roi
ils dépendants parce que les chinois ne
savent pas faire d'un certain nombre de
composants électroniques
donc pour les états unis c'est très
pratique de bloquer roi ouais là dessus
en plus 3 ou est dépendant aussi pour
vivre et pour développer la salle g de
ses ventes de téléphones
donc il suffit pour les chiffres et les
américains de favoriser le concurrent
droit web os en chine qui est si hormis
qui lui continue à avoir accès
certains des composants électroniques et
surtout accès à google on l'a vu un
vendredi le ministère américain du
commerce a donc décidé d'imposer des
sanctions à la chine concernant huawei
la chine qui prévoit de répondre
d'imposer des mesures quelles mesures de
rétorsion au final la chine qui n'a pas
précisé la nature de ces réponses qu'il
comptait apporter
la chine est actuellement dans une
position relativement difficile pour
imposer des mesures de rétorsion elle
pourrait arrêter d'exporter des masques
et des 1,50 d'équipement de ce type il
est évident que sur le plan mondial et
sur le plan de sa réputation ça serait
assez catastrophique donc la chine est
un petit peu obligé de faire le gros dos
et de subir pour le moment et c'est pour
ça qu'on avait les discours du ministre
des affaires étrangères chinois qui sont
ça reste au niveau du discours il ya pas
de précisions sur les mesures qui
pourraient être prises qui serait quand
même relativement cosmétiques donc pas
de sanction à s'attendre de la part de
la chine selon vous alors pas de porte
pas de sanction d'importance ait pas de
sanction qui pourrait avoir la portance
de ce qui est fait contre wade il est
évident que pour les journalistes
chinois les journées américain africain
risque d'avoir quelques quelques soucis
pour pouvoir exercer leur métier
merci jean vincent brisset d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'iris spécialiste de la chine